when I first met this woman I saw rose
and I latched on to her I told her baby
I don't want to marry I just want to be
your man Rose told me I told him if he
wasn't a man kind and move out the way
so the marrying kind could find me
that's what she told me you're in my way
you're blocking the view move out the
way so I can find me a husband wait Cory
I want him to help me with this fence he
got recruited by a college football team
it ain't gonna get him nowhere if he'd
be like you in the sports he gonna be
all right
okay but two men never played baseball
good as you and what it ever give me I
ain't got a pot to piss in or a window
to throw it out of hey pop can I ask you
a question how come you never liked me
what law is there say I got to like you
a man is supposed to take care of his
family you live in my house for your
belly with my food put your behind on my
bed because you're my son now don't you
go through life worrying about whether
somebody like you or not
you best be making sure they're doing
right by you
boy we just trying to fill out yo shoes
I don't want him to be like me I want
him to get his far away from my life as
he possibly can get you the only decent
thing about nummy rolls you can't be
nobody for who you are Troy that's all
you got to measure yourself against the
world out there
well I got some time I don't know how to
tell you this white alright why you
ought to know is talent but you ever
give me your feet their bones and
pumping hard you've never done nothing
behold me back afraid I was gonna be
better than you
everything that boy do he do for you
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place for 18
years I've been standing with you I got
a life too
don't you think I had dreams and hopes
what about my life what about me
some people build fences to keep people
out and other people build fences to
keep people in hey pop hmm that's your
question how come you never liked me
like you what law is there say I got to
like you no all right then
don't you eat every day answer me when I
talk to you don't you eat every day yeah
as long as you in my house you put a
cell on the end of it when you talk to
me yes sir you eat every day yes sir got
a roof over your head yes sir I clothes
on your back yes sir why you think that
is cuz he hell I know it's cuz of me but
why do you think that is cuz you like me
like you I go out of here every morning
I bust my butt cuz I like you you're
about the biggest fool ever saw a man is
supposed to take care of his family
you live in my house for your belly with
my food
put your behind on my bed because you're
my son it's my duty to take care of you
I hope on sibility to you I ain't got to
like you now I don't give you everything
I got to give you I give you your life
me and your mama work that out between
us unlike in your black ass wasn't part
of the bargain now don't you go through
life worrying about whether somebody
like you or not you best be making sure
that they're doing right by you
you understand what I'm singing
everything that boy do he do for you
it's not easy for me to admit that I've
been standing in the same place for 18
years understanding with you I get 18
years of my life to stand in the same
spot as you
[Music]
you